ein wunderschöner morgen erwartet uns
hier in unserer kleinen süßen minecraft
fällt meine lieben freunde wir wollen
gar nicht langer zeit verlieren denn wir
haben direkt wieder extrem viel zu tun
für heute zunächst einmal muss ich mir
nämlich hier weizen rausnehmen das
schaufel habe ich schon in der hand und
belaufen zu unserem kuhstall hier unten
denn der weg hier ist gewachsen wurde in
die kommentare geschrieben von er könne
jetzt hier reingehen können wir schon
ein bisschen hier auch alles mehr
durcheinander machen und ich nehme jetzt
auch mal eben kurz das weizen in die
hand
[Applaus]
[Musik]
wer sich wie der oberbau hier wie hier
werden auf jeden fall jetzt mal ein
bisschen spaß haben
ich muss jetzt allerdings ganz kurz mal
eben raus zack so ihr bleibt da drin
und dass wir auch ohne die kommentare
geschrieben wurde war dass ich den
kompletten weg unten zu unserem boot
einfach auch aus lagerfeuer machen soll
ich hatte da er irgendwie den dieser weg
hier bestand nämlich bisher aus dieser
erde die ich einfach dafür genommen
hatte dann wird mir allerdings
geschrieben
[Musik]
jetzt haben ganz schnell gar keinen weg
mehr also hier mal eben alles ausbessern
hier vorne kommt auch noch sand hin dann
mache ich mir hier auch noch so ein
bisschen was hin das schiff warum sieht
auf jeden fall ein bisschen schöner aus
als vorher was ich will dann auch noch
gedacht habe war ich bringe ich will
keine tiere umbringen was ich mir
gedacht habe war dass ich die laterne da
oben mal so ein bisschen weiter runter
setzte weil ich das doch ein bisschen zu
hoch noch finde von daher brauche ich
jetzt einfach die laterne ab hier nehme
ich eine kette die habe ich mir gerade
schon gemacht und hängen die laterne
hier ein bisschen weiter runter
ich weiß nicht ob ich da ein bisschen
vom pingelig bringen bei solchen sachen
aber ich finde so auf jeden fall ein
bisschen schöner wenn man sich das
anguckt dann hängt wie so ein bisschen
tiefer ist schon geil aus was wir
erreicht haben der letzten folge oder
dann werde ich mir nun auch ein bisschen
fisch mitnehmen zum beispiel den rohen
lachse denn mir wurde in die kommentare
geschrieben und dafür habe ich auch hier
unten den namen tag schon mit dabei dass
ich einen delfin zwar nicht so wichtig
nehmen kann wenn ich allerdings auf ihn
drauf
wenn ich mit einem nennt heck auf einen
delfinen rechtsweg mache kann ich ihm
wohl einen namen geben und ich nenne ihn
ja eh schon die ganze zeit flipper von
daher wurden mir geschrieben hätte ihn
doch mal wirklich einfach flipper und
dafür braucht dieses namensschild das
habe ich mitgenommen den roten lack ich
wie gesagt mitgenommen damit ich da mit
den delfinen füttern kann denn dann
führt er ein zu einem schatz als ich
hoffe dass flipper kommt aber bisher ist
er noch nicht da ist ja auch schön aus
hier alles mit diesem kleinen inselchen
und so sind generell wasser in minecraft
ist so so unfassbar geil einfach davon
das habe ich noch nie so richtig
entdeckt
guckt euch das mal an wollen wir sind
fetteste loch ist dass der wille da
vorne
hier ist einfach von krater im
wachsenden in die kommentare geschrieben
wurde ich habe mich nicht auf eine höhle
episode vorbereitet und will das auch
eigentlich nicht machen gerade weil ich
andere pläne habe
wir wurden nicht und in die kommentare
geschrieben dass sich die diamanten
vergessen habe im dorf und außerdem eine
unnötige kiste gepackt habe aber ich
würde sagen wie kommen irgendwann in
einer anderen folge mal wieder hierhin
und dann werden wir mal wieder eine
komplette höhen folge machen da ist das
dorf meine lieben freunde bevor wir
allerdings gleich da sind möchte ich
noch eine kleine geschichte erzählen
denn die habe ich mir eigentlich zu
recht bereitet dafür dass wenn wir lange
zeit im boot sitzen aber wir sind ja
jetzt schon davon daher erzähle ich euch
die story einfach gleich denn wir werden
auch noch ein bisschen weiter rumfahren
alte der eisen kohle sich ja richtig am
arsch aus
das stimmt hier vorne ist unsere kiste
und smaragde lasse ich trotzdem einfach
mal hier weil ich dir hier zum traden
brauche was ich allerdings mal kurz
probieren könnte wäre das noch mal mit
dem pult so drama unserer bibliothek
karten abo jetzt rechtsklick und dichter
feuerschutz 1 ich nehme jetzt nochmal
meine smaragde hier raus und ich nehme
auch mal papier hier raus weil damit
kann man wohl auch ein bisschen traden
ich mache jetzt einfach mal meinen
ersten trade was für ein geschäft ich
habe wirklich viel zu viel papier meine
lieben freunde deswegen werde ich jetzt
einfach mal ein bisschen handeln und
kann ihnen dadurch hoch stufen die frage
ist jetzt allerdings was ich mir gerade
stelle warum geht das nicht höre muss
ich jetzt verraten oder die würden
schreibt mir das mal ja genau so sieht
man dann aus ich packe jetzt das
restliche papier und die smaragde erst
mal hier rein die brauchen wir nämlich
nicht und es wird schon dunkel auch
deswegen werde ich auf jeden fall hier
kurz übernachten ihr fragt euch jetzt
wahrscheinlich auch luca warum ist hier
tnt bei dir im inventar dafür setzen wir
uns nämlich ins brötchen fahren los und
fahren einfach mal so ein bisschen
weiter würde ich sagen also dahin kommen
wir her da wohne ich deswegen würde ich
sagen fangen hier an der insel so ein
bisschen vorbei hier vorne da ist ja das
schiff ragt gewesen was wir quasi
abgebaut haben und unseren schatz
gefunden haben auch mit den diamanten
und so weiter und so fort das war ganz
geil die sache ist allerdings ich habe
tnt mitgenommen weil ich ein großes ziel
habe was ich da was geht da ab
das ist zwar nicht das was ich suche
aber das sieht sehr eindrucksvoll
geradeaus mein perspektivisches ziel in
diesem projekt ist ja der riesige
unterwasser tunnel da habe ich auch
einige kommentare bekommen von wegen
luca das macht gar keinen sinn nur krieg
platzangst und muss dann schwämme
benutzen und zweitens wort ist ja was
ist das
was ist mein ziel für dieses projekt ist
eine riesige unterwasser tun und dafür
brauchen wir ganz ganz ganz ganz ganz
ganz ganz ganz viel sand und zwar genau
genommen 1800 stück weil was ist das
[Musik]
das ist irgendwie lover hart flucht des
verschwindens ok glück drei okay das ist
sehr stark
ich will das ding nicht anziehen wenn
ich ein bisschen schiss davor habe weil
letztes mal hatte ich dieses ding
angezogen dann hab ich das noch einmal
ein bisschen gestorben bin in die kiste
nämlich auch einfach mal mit ist kann
man immer mal ganz gut gebrauchen
obsidian könnte ich ja eigentlich kann
ich glaube sie dann auch mal mitnehmen
und sonst so ich wollte euch ja noch
eine kleine story erzählen und zwar bin
ich in letzter zeit zunehmend
vergesslich geworden und die sache ist
und das habe ich auch schon im podcast
erzählt dass ich und dadurch ist mir das
ganze zeit aufgefallen in letzter zeit
mir oft abends zweimal die zähne putze
klar es gibt schlimmeres so meine zähne
freuen sich so alles easy
allerdings ist das problem dass ich oft
halt deine besten geregelten
essenszeiten habe dass er sich irgendwie
um acht uhr abends dann putzt sie mit
dementsprechend direkt danach die zähne
weil ich mir dann denke da muss ich halt
später nicht machen und dann wenn ich
dann irgendwann ins bett gehe 34 stunden
später putze mir mal die zähne und merke
dann beim zähneputzen moment ich habe
mir ja schon die zähne geputzt kann da
irgendjemand vielleicht nie leighton das
an sich ist ja nicht weiter schlimm die
sache ist allerdings dass das jetzt mit
dem zähneputzen bei mir irgendwie so ein
ding geworden ist dass ich irgendwie mir
gestern abend die zähne nicht mit meiner
zahnpasta sondern einfach mit
waschlotionen geputzt habe ja ich habe
einfach nicht meine zahnpasta auf die
zahnbürste gepackt sondern habe die
zahnbürste irgendwie völlig
selbstverständlich unter meinem kleinen
seifenspender gepackt kann ich das ja
nicht abbauen
ich kann das abbauen magma blanc keine
ahnung was mag man blöcke bringen aber
ich nehme ich jetzt einfach mal mit wir
haben
[Musik]
würde ich gern aber ich weiß nicht wie
das geht falls sich irgend jemand von
euch auch mal die zähne mit
waschlotionen geputzt hat das hört sich
komplett falschen aber das scheint zwar
gerne in die kommentare ich weiß nicht
was hier abgeht mit den bergen und ich
weiß auch jetzt schon nicht mehr von wo
wir gekommen sind ich habe ich komplett
verfahren glaube ich allerdings brauchen
wir irgendwie eine wüste hier halten wir
einfach mal an das boten nämlich
selbstverständlich mit nicht das was
nachher noch vergessen hier hinten das
sieht schon nach einem sehr trockenen
biom aus ich habe mich nämlich vor der
episode war so ein bisschen rein gelesen
da stand es gibt auf jeden fall
seltenere biome als die wüste aber wenn
der wüste kommt dann auf jeden fall
neben solchen bio muss halt auch
ziemlich trocken ist hier sind auf jeden
fall viele schweine am start da können
wir theoretisch auch ein schwein
mitnehmen die sich fortpflanzen können
bei mir das sieht auch schon echt cool
aus tieren
bisschen wie ein könig
wir alle wissen doch
[Musik]
gott oh mein gott
dahinter guten morgen wir sind da
angekommen in einem dörfchen in der
wüste alter viel besser könnte es ja
nicht vor wieso hat der zombie dahinten
bessere schwerer sich wir nehmen jetzt
auf jeden fall mit
wo kommt der her wo kommt er her kommt
ja so nämlich ne tweet sehr gut danke ja
eine hand wäscht die andere wir gehen
jetzt mal endlich unser ziel für die
heutige episode an meine lieben freunde
also gleich gucken wir natürlich auch ob
die hier im dorf einige kisten haben uns
weiter und so fort allerdings möchte ich
erstmal schauen wie viel sonne
tnt stück wirklich an schaden macht weil
hier schon stein
ich setze jetzt einfach mal hier sollten
her ein und dann schauen wir mal
und dann schauen wir mal funktioniert
und kummer wie viel sand wir jetzt
einfach haben
das ist ich würde sagen das nächste tnt
setzen wir einfach mal hier an diesem
berg ran weil jetzt alles voll mit
sandstein und wenn wir da jetzt sind tnt
reinsetzen dann müsste daher alles
theoretisch darunter fliegen von daher
hier tmt hin hier die fackel daneben und
beim und es jetzt gehen wir aber
wirklich ans eingemachte freuen ich
setze hier einfach mal das
ich muss es ganz mit dem tnt noch ein
bisschen üben ich würde allerdings sagen
wir graben immer kurzum sohn erde turm
weg und laufen jetzt auch noch mal
hinten ins dorf um einfach mal zu gucken
was die da hinten in ihren kisten so
drin haben wir haben zwar gar keinen
platz mehr im inventar allerdings kann
es nie schaden hat zumindest mal kurz zu
schauen hier vorne ist auch eine höhle
da könnte man auch mal reingehen
ich würde sagen dass ich mir mal kurz
eine kleine baseball-teams ich weiß
nicht was das da das ist glaube dass ein
so keramik blöcken die sache ist dass
wir auf jeden fall hier noch ein
bisschen was erkunden müssen und ich
muss sandfarben in der nächsten folge
ich werde hier auf jeden fall schädiger
startplatz auch hier hier ein bisschen
bleiben und auf jeden fall die nächste
folge auch noch hier in der wüste
verbringen hier ist eine kiste und wir
haben nur essen um tonklumpen
ich werde mich hier vorne einfach mal
eine kleine base machen und neue kiste
hinsetzt und alle sachen reinpacken die
ich jetzt gerade erst mal nicht so
richtig benötige das essen nämlich mal
mit hier das namensschild
da wollte man eigentlich den delfinen
geben der ist allerdings leider nicht
gekommen heute der eisen cola bistum der
garde hat sich jetzt einfach hier selbst
eingesperrt kartentisch
[Musik]
von ea ziehen die karten gegeneinander
spielen keine ahnung was das ding ist
sieht auf jeden fall ziemlich cool aus
generell ist die westliche extrem leid
und ich feiere auch dass die nebenan
also dieses andere bio ich weiß nicht 8
30 noch savanne oder so fühle ich sehr
ich fühle mich ein bisschen wie bei
könig der löwen
allerdings würde ich an der stadt die
heutige folge jetzt auch beenden es ist
ziemlich kraftlos sich die folge nicht
bei mir im dorf beende aber das wird
jetzt auch wirklich viel zu lange dauern
dort wieder hinzufahren
von daher meine lieben freunde wenn euch
die heutige die sohle gefallen hat dann
lasst keinen eigenen daumen hoch und ein
video ihr da schreibt mir weiterhin
gerne tipps und tricks und in die
kommentare und wir sehen uns soll morgen
tik tok tuesday kommen oder noch eine
voll gemeinschaft ihr entscheidet
schreib und in die kommentare minecraft
oder tik tok tuesday was ihr sehen wollt
was mehr kommentare hat wird morgen
kommen von daher sehen wir uns morgen
auf jeden fall um 20 uhr im neuen video
wieder chelsea
[Musik]